what's happening reject nation I'm G
elbow then I'm J Humphrey you're gonna
watch WWE best moves a 20-18 from the
channel guru-guru sicl4 i be i
girlfriend's gonna be happy I'm watching
this she's a huge WWE fan and the most
you hear of us following it is through
all these reactions that patrons like
Cameron French and Lynnae request one of
our top war tears on our patreon page
for everybody to request some stuff we
do and put up on YouTube and today cup
some sort of came out on crooked nose
French let's do this Daniel Bryan
yeah it's right there nice yeah midair
boos Rollins
[Music]
stop screwin up on his shoulders
Oh pencil
powerbomb friends gun
[Applause]
the Rey Mysterio Oh ass Haneda
[Applause]
[Music]
so we're comment right away tell me that
it and leave the times that was a woman
very shapely Mary it's all fake those
people are really experiencing
Wow God the way they just toss each
other hug Oh
dude really game
it's going conscience that that was like
super smash I'm in pay in Washington oh
my brother did that to me when I was
younger
[Applause]
dangle they're so good at diving through
those ropes
[Applause]
oh you just let him have your leg there
man
instead it's all the midair ones like
like how do you not get hurt hit the
little you're in there Wow
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
like I'm buzzed tackled woody out of the
car cool
[Music]
well these guys have must have really
bad headaches itch or insane neck
muscles Wow
you like black widow tombs yeah they're
for real life they make people flipping
real fights yes
[Music]
[Applause]
Dolf boom Rhonda yeah little Brian
[Applause]
boy finally you get to do something cool
looking slide that one yes Wow Oh
[Music]
it looks like a blue Kevin's god it's so
good at flipping impress me the most
oh really
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
like watching
goddamn
[Applause]
- these girls are hot whoa yeah
yes
[Applause]
it's got a third guitar in here
whoa I look dazed you got a really love
doing this huh yeah you have to love
doing huh that's the guy from might here
navel lasers
stick it to her yeah she looks like my
friend Wow
[Applause]
that guy is good at the day's look
[Music]
haha that's cool though
[Applause]
good to have around it whoa
[Applause]
[Applause]
no Becky Lynch is the hottest one of
them all people in critical fact which
is the man
[Applause]
Aaron Hall this guy just always a
regular played guitar
[Applause]
trash that a mouthguard
oh good the guys good at Benny visual
phony ouch
I feel like this is literally every
great wrestling home for today oh no you
must have heard himself querida yeah
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
Oh
oh okay
gwen stefani wrestler oh man that was a
journey we don't wanna pay a lot of pain
we're doing the hard work by watching
these oh okay got more Becky Lynch
Olivia showed me this video where Becky
Lynch was like [ __ ] gushing blood I
mean she was still just in the match
just like taunting and everything yeah I
was like damn this girl's hot tough as
nails and my ass you can spit up blood
like it's nothing yeah dude that's sexy
I didn't realize how a lot of these guys
have to be semi parkour I don't know
what that ring is called where you got
one ring here connected to another ring
and he's just like him yeah yeah this
made me realize I mean like yeah the
physical prowess and like how muscular I
gotta be but also like the physics
because the amount of like flipping
these guys are doing in the amount of
like redirection of momentum cuz you got
like dudes diving into each other and
then being flipped around and like
thrown up and tossed and I think that's
my favorite kind is when it starts to
look like super smash and they're just
like throwing each other around and
flipping and bouncing I get really into
the one that's it's like the two heavy
guys who seem to be rather light on
their feet they're like huge dudes and
they're like we're gonna hoppin around
hitting off stuff you don't look like
based off your weight distribution that
you'd be able to move like that but
that's pretty impressive remedy to be
hit by you some people really just when
they're like spasming you know sometimes
it's fake but then there are times where
it's very real
yes I struck a nerve in their body I
don't want to see a compilation of the
wrestling mishaps of 2018 I bet there is
why no no no I'd love to see that oh I
love all the painful ones dude you're
like this just got real
like yeah I would died during wrestling
or would it be someone has at least had
to have died from complications someone
has to have like yeah I have a bear
lies case but the kind of damage you do
it and your next when you slap
especially when you like those are the
ones where I really feel it when you're
like you're slamming like your neck down
on it I dropped on their heads yeah you
can cause serious concussion I mean I'm
sure people got concussions and
everything but damn you must know I
wonder like what the long-term damage is
on some of these people oh yeah oh well
yeah you gotta come out with at least a
little trace brain damage that and it
also makes me cringe every time they
like slams somebody's back against the
edge of like though the edge of the Ring
it's yeah like a bein the style back
break I would be fascinated to actually
see some kind of documentary where
people like explain how these moves work
and what you got to keep in mind cuz I
gotta imagine like you know you tighten
up certain muscles or whatever to
protect yourself and you brace I'm
trying to watch the movie fighting with
my family cuz if it that would give me
some insight into like what the training
regimen is like I've heard people say
like ok we're gonna do this move we're
gonna do this move but there's some room
like did you guys must have rehearsed
this right I did like that you have to
have rehearse this because I think you
could accidentally murder someone so
what they need to talk about what you're
gonna do to survive that I wonder if
this is like a concert where it's like a
lot of guys they have their lists of
moves picked out but then you got some
guys who change it up every night you've
got to be really on your game to play
with those again I've heard of wrestlers
getting into like actual like bar brawls
do I have some fans of wrestling can be
or they taunt the personality as if they
like you know they're at an actual event
but they're just at a bar or something
so wrestlers will get into fights but
wonder if any of these professional
wrestlers if they're in a real like fist
fight
do they ever resort to I'm not gonna
punch you but hey I'm gonna flip you
over the bar bounce you off a table and
then kneecap you in the face some of
these guys are just like insanely
acrobatic but it has to have some type
of gymnastics background because some of
them are just so insanely good at
multiple flips the way they some of them
Bend even oh damn what the hell moves
here I've never seen before well yeah
that's what fascinates me I guess about
wrestling amid all the other types of
combat based sports you know like MMA
and boxing and stuff like that is like
there is the pageantry element and I
feel like acrobatics and gymnastics are
definitely a physical athletic skill but
also they help with that pageantry
because if you can do like crazy flips
and contortions like that's only gonna
help your character I would imagine oh
yeah absolutely and I love those ones
where there's like one do where there
was multiple people on the ground and
then he flips off the top like I'm
sitting here wondering cuz it's so many
different people and I'm like oh these
guys want like a clan or they always
it's like a group fight or they all
against each other what's going on Oh
looks like a Royal Rumble or a
free-for-all or something like yeah oh
man that was great that was great
thanks Cameron French for requesting
this buddy man I've shouted you out so
many times now and we primarily just
talk a lot about films and our opinions
how he thinks will Poulter would be a
good Batman of all the blame for Will
Smith as the genie should go to the CGI
department and not towards Will Smith
just so you know if we ever disagree in
person I'm gonna bounce off a wall wrap
my legs around you flip you over the
back of my head and slam your neck
against the ground as a way of respect
for the things you love for the passions
you have that's the way I roll man it's
my way of showing how to respectfully
disagree specifically with you I will
throw you into a crowd of chairs smash
your head on a table might even go to
the Guitar Center spend $1,000 on the
highest expensive guitar acoustic
specifically and smell it on the back of
your head a very rare one
I might even upgrade it to electric
guitar and smash that on you just do one
of each man double fist it right both
sides of your head your ears will be
ringing it'll be perfect I feel like
there's a problem with fandoms nowadays
of people not knowing how to disagree I
feel like this is the best way you and I
could do it in the ring we're just on
the streets on the streets guys you can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell and we'll catch
you guys